my name is peril wolf and I am the lead
singer songwriter for the band peril and
we are an all-girl Hasidic rock band in
Crown Heights Brooklyn all of our live
concerts are for women only
I grew up in a Hasidic home so having a
separation of the sexes in certain
places is pretty common there's a law in
Judaism for men not to listen to the
singing voice of a woman who is not an
immediate family member
I would say one of the biggest
misconceptions that people have about
the Hasidic community people think that
women are totally oppressed that women
can't be leaders I felt very much
empowered as a woman spending time with
other powerful women and having time to
connect and having our own space women
deserve a space to rock out the response
from the solicita community has been
really positive mostly you know let's
let's empower women let's make something
new for women when fans come over and
tell you I felt so comfortable tonight I
felt like I could dance I feel like I
could be myself or I really felt the
powerful energy being around other women
I'm like okay we're doing something
important and that's really all that
matters